i'm at birch anger mi tease institute
community and equity officer it's my
privilege to welcome you to this
community dialogue responding to recent
tragedies to introduce the event and to
prepare you for the work ahead i begin
with a poem by juan felipe herrera poet
laureate of the United States called at
the crossroads a sudden American poem
r.i.p Follette falando Castile Alton
sterling Dallas police officers Lauren
errands michael crowell michael j smith
brent thompson and patrick summary / and
all their families and to all those
injured let us celebrate the lives of
all as we reflect and pray and meditate
on their brutal deaths let us celebrate
those who marched at night and who spoke
of peace and chanted black lives matter
let us celebrate the officers dressed in
blues ready to protect let us know the
departed as we did not know them before
their faces bodies names what they loved
their words the stories they often spoke
before we return to the usual business
of our days let us know their lives
intimately let us take this moment and
as impossible as this may sound let us
find the beauty in their lives in the
midst of their sudden and never imagined
vanishing let us consider the Dallas
shooter what made him what happened in
Afghanistan what flames burned inside
who was that man in Baton Rouge with the
red shirt selling CDs in the parking lot
who was that man in Minnesota toppled on
the car seat with a perforated arm and a
continent shaped flood of blood on his
white tee who was that man prone and
gone by the night pillar of El Camino AL
Central College in Dallas this could be
the first step in the new evaluation of
our society this could be the first step
of all of our lives this is why we are
here we were invited by president rife
who sends his regrets that he cannot be
present because of international travel
but many of MIT senior leaders are here
including Provost Marty Schmidt and
Chancellor Cindy Barnhart we are here in
answer to President Reich's call when he
wrote i believe our leading civic
institutions have a responsibility to
speak clearly against these corrosive
forces and to act practically to inspire
and create positive change in his time
of need the MIT community has an
opportunity to offer service of great
value to our society to our country and
perhaps to the world by applying our
unique strengths to the problem at hand
but we are also here because of our
individual cries of pain pangs of fear
and desire for peace and healing MIT
prides itself on its mind and hand today
we are exercising our heart our goal
today is not to solve a problem this
event is not about solutions we can't
solve a problem we can't hear each other
talking about we can't solve a problem
we can't hear each other talking about
first we must listen to each other with
our whole hearts
to feel to cry to be held together you
will be uncomfortable today if you're
not uncomfortable we're not growing stay
with us take strength from our students
who shared their vulnerability in the
MIT admissions blogs read them and share
them with your friends and family take
strength and knowing that everyone here
faculty summer students alumni MIT
police support staff everyone is here to
be together in a caring community we
care deeply so deeply that it sometimes
hurts that is okay pay attention now
here's the program after the next
speaker you will focus on your table at
a group as a group each table has a
facilitator who is prepared to help work
with everyone to address some questions
of the heart your facilitator will
present discussion ground rules we
invite you to respect you'll have until
120 p.m. to explore together there's no
question and answer to the whole group
we're in four different rooms you will
have a chance to send notes and
recommendations to the organizers by
writing them on index cards at each
table we will collect these and share a
summary with the community by early fall
I want to give thanks to those who made
this event possible starting with
President rife who's passionate call for
a response to the killings last week has
brought us together thank you to Ted
Johnson and his big team at institute
events and MIT video productions for
pulling together a major event in one
week thank you to the working group on
support staff issues for their
volunteers and thank you to the many
facilitators serving today thank you to
colon Brander to Alice Johnson Abigail
Francis and letari can t Chester Barrow
dying at a Creighton please join me in
thanking them all
after this event we invite you to a
post-event time for prayer and
reflection with chaplain Andrew innocent
in room 491 upstairs where you can
decompress and contribute if you wish to
an art project called thoughts from the
heart now it is my pleasure to introduce
MIT area director kester Barrow of the
Division of Student Life who will offer
some important framing of today's
conversations mr. Barrow
you